you know what else they're terrible at
trick-or-treating the [ __ ] worst
now let me just start by saying I was
very poor growing up right so a day full
of free [ __ ] yes thank you and I don't
know about you guys but when I was
growing up we had two options for
costumes it was ghost or hobo and I
learned after that first Halloween when
they took the [ __ ] crusty sheet off
my brother's bed I'm like no I'm not a
ghost ever again ever again I spent the
entire night like this
so this generation of [ __ ] first of
all in my neighborhood what happens is
they get a bunch of kids together and
then they have one parent take them out
so most of us can stay home and our
candy so when some years it's your year
to take your kids rap
so as my year to take group kids around
and the first of all they show up at my
house and they're all holding these
pansy-ass little plastic pumpkins I'm
like what's going on we're ready to go
trick-or-treating what we are ready to
go and I was like no you're not
now go home and get your freaking
pillowcases right now cuz we walk down
the street like we had didn't skip down
the street with a pumpkin that dude's
dad would have beat the [ __ ] out of you
for sure first house we take him to
right this lady gave him apples you know
what they said to her thank you and I
was like what get over get over get over
here right now
you take the apple out of that fancy
pumpkin he's gonna throw it at that
house right now
break a window have some respect for
Halloween and the people who came before
you please but daddy they're nutritious
and delicious nutritious and delicious
I ate so much candy on Halloween I [ __ ]
a zagnut are you kidding me
I have diabetes on November 1st [ __ ] you
the next house we go to houses dark
there's a porch light on and there's a
bowl on the front porch and then the
boulders a note that says please take
one now look when I was growing up that
meant one whole bowl by the way Bowl and
everything [ __ ] you for leaving your
[ __ ] on the patio your Bowl will be down
the street in the bushes with the last
five bowls I stole from here but they're
literally on the porch like trying to
pick out the candy
but Dad it says please just take one it
doesn't matter what it says because when
we get home and you're counting candy
you want to have the most candy my son
was like dad it's not a competition I
said the [ __ ] it isn't whether you think
it is or not you better have the most
candy out of this group and then this is
the game this is the kid that finally
drove me into the house where I couldn't
take it anymore
there was a kid lagging behind the whole
time nice enough kid but you know the
kid with the spider-man costume was like
four sizes too small and he's walking
behind the group like this Halloween is
so much exercise
you're walking what the [ __ ] yeah but I
have to carry this too
do you ever remember being tired on
Halloween
no you filled up the pillowcase you ran
home you dumped it out maybe you snorted
a Pixy stick and you ran out the dark
[Applause]
now maybe you ran back in to tell your
dad don't you eat my Snickers old man I
swear to God what a bunch of [ __ ]
[Music]
you